Speaker 1: You really have to see this to
believe it.
The very same Republican congressman who denied
that there was any insurrection on January
6th has now been caught in pictures showing
him looking panicked and barricading the doors
of the House of Representatives with furniture
to try to stop the insurrectionists who he
claimed don't exist from coming into the House
of Representatives.
I'm speaking about Republican Congressman
Andrew Clide.
Just last week, he said the riot looked like
a, quote, normal tourist visit.
Those are comments for which he was rightly
excoriated.
Ridiculous comments.
Here is a picture of the same Andrew Clide
who said insurrection.
No, this is just a tour.
Here he is pushing a piece of furniture surrounded
by security guards up against the doors of
the House of Representatives.
That's a normal tourist visit.
Normal tourist visits require members of the
House of Representatives to barricade the
doors with furniture.
Here is another picture of Cleide.
And he looks, I mean to say he looks scared
for his life.
Is not an exaggeration.
It doesn't look like a normal congressional
tourist visit to me, this was Clyde's original
comment.
You really have to see it to believe it.
Let me be clear.
There was no insurrection.
And to call it an insurrection, in my opinion,
is a bold faced lie.
Watching the TV footage of those who entered
the capital and walked through Statuary Hall
showed people in an orderly fashion staying
between the stanchions and robes, taking videos
and pictures.
You know, if you didn't know the TV footage
was a video from January the 6th,
Speaker 2: you would actually think it was
a normal tourist visit.
Speaker 1: It was a normal tourist visit.
And yet Congressman Andrew Clide holding up
furniture against the door to prevent the
insurrectionists from breaking in.
I haven't heard a response from Clide yet
to these pictures being uncovered, but what
could he possibly say?
Oh, he was trying to pull down the furniture
to let the peaceful visitors in the images
deceptive because he was taking down the barricades,
not putting them up.
I can't even imagine what kind of response
there would be here, but that's one of the
most absurd that I can think of.
Another possibility would be like maybe to
argue semantics.
Yes, they were breaking in.
Yes.
Some of them were being violent.
Yes, they were trespassing.
But we can't call it an insurrection because
they didn't really have a plan for how they
would govern if they succeeded in overthrowing
the government and stopping the process of
counting the electoral votes, like in some
literal semantic sense, because they didn't
have a plan for taking over control of the
government.
It's not an insurrection.
I don't know.
But bottom line, this is yet another attempt
to normalize the situation.
And what this goes to is that if they can
make us think, if they can make us believe
that what took place was normal and just blown
out of proportion, maybe by the left, maybe
they were not even real trumpets, as they
love to say, then they and their fellow Republicans
might be off the hook for any wrongdoing in
pushing for that January 6th insurrection
by spending months claiming the election was
stolen.
And that, of course, includes Donald Trump
as well.
In normal circumstances, by which I mean sometime
in the past, not recently, we might have thrown
these people out of government by now.
But Republican victimhood has allowed them
to cry foul, to blame everybody else and to
continue to wreak havoc and do damage in their
Senate and House of Representative jobs and
roles.
And case in point, yesterday's story about
Marjorie Taylor Green and her long record
of harassment of fellow Congresswoman Alexandria
Cacio Cortez.
That type of behavior would get almost anyone
fired from their job.
If you treated a coworker in that way.
If in my organization, I found out that somebody
did what Marjorie Taylor Green has done to
Alexandria Castillo, Cortez, I would have
to meet with them and I would have to say,
you can't work here anymore.
This is it.
That's not how this works.
It's not allowable.
We can't have that.
It's outrageous.
But they have, to some degree successfully
normalized all of the stuff.
And that has also included obvious lying,
obvious lying has been completely normalized
as well.
So, you know, if I could wrap up with something
optimistic or Forward-Looking that is anything
other than than just horrible desperation
for some kind of semblance of normality, I
would.
But I don't see any appetite from the American
right wing, from the Republican Party, from
particularly this Trumpy and wing of the Republican
Party to hold any of these people accountable.
And so the fear is and I think that the last
few months have shown us that it's a well-founded
fear.
The fear is they will continue to do this
stuff and attempt to rewrite history, normalize
absolutely horrendous things well into the
twenty, twenty two election.
And if Donald Trump gets his way and he gets
to decide who is on the approved list of good,
good boys and bad boys, good girls and bad
girls and who wins in twenty, twenty two,
not only may Republicans take over the House,
it may be a particularly Trumpy and Republican
wing that takes over the House and it sets
the stage for Trump or maybe if you can imagine
someone even worse in twenty twenty four.
So I don't think this is trivial stuff.
And I know we started with just the kernel,
which is a guy who was barricading the doors
now claims that really wasn't an insurrection.
And it is a form of gaslighting that leads
to a lot of potentially horrible things getting
into the midterms in the twenty, twenty four
election.
So we will continue to follow it.
And there are others like Clide making similarly
outrageous statements, which maybe we'll talk
about later this week.
Remember that Monday, Memorial Day.
We are doing a one day membership special,
if you've been thinking, I don't know, maybe
I'll get one of those memberships, get a membership
before they run out on Monday, Memorial Day,
we'll be doing a big one day discount.
You can get on my mailing list at David Pakman
Dotcom and Monday, Memorial Day, you'll get
an email telling you how to sign up.
Let us not forget that this program is an
independent media program, we have no corporate
backing, we have no big corporations or rich
dudes or gals fueling our program.
And as a result, we depend mostly on individual
subscriptions from people just like you.
I've met many of them.
They really are just like you
in all of the best ways.
And you can sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
You will get access to the Daily Bonus Show,
as well as commercial free audio and video
streams of the show.
And if you would like a discount, you can
use the code better.
Twenty one to save hugely off of the cost
of a membership.